last time i was single i was 24 and the
dating pool was everyone and now it's
like a shallow puddle of age-appropriate
men who are old and gross and i don't
want to do that selena gomez ladies and
gents the reigning queen of tick-tock
thank you this time bringing the lols by
mocking her dating life we hope
everybody enjoys it the 29 year old
triple threat has a good laugh at her
single status on tick-tock lip-syncing
to this scene of leslie mann's character
in the other woman last time i was
single i was 24 and the dating pool was
everyone and now it's like a shallow
puddle of age-appropriate men who are
old and gross and i don't want to do
that i mean cell really commits to the
moment last time i was single i was 24
and the dating pool was everyone the
only murders in the building star who
turns 30 in july writes in the caption
me walking into my 30s i'm okay with it
though
oh my goodness yeah but this isn't the
first time that selena who previously
dated justin bieber and the weeknd has
poked fun at her dating life on the app
i mean i'm just really trying to holla
at you forever how about me for what you
said holler at me for what
last month selena posted that clip
writing maybe this is why i'm single
don't believe a damn word i mean you're
pretty
oh you got a nice smile oh
i love your personality
and she recently shared this clip which
features a strong warning going out
tonight so hide your men not because i
want them but because i don't want to
see a singular man on my outing
yes selena she doesn't need a man to
know she's fire would you rate yourself
on a scale of one to ten i'm a ten a ten
yeah that's like flawless though yeah i
am flawless your father okay so like
what
let's be real this time all right so
like on one to ten like for real like
realistically what would you rate
yourself and she's here to remind you to
stay confident and live your best life
too i'm just so confident and
comfortable and i feel free more than
i've ever felt in my whole life i feel
comfortable in my skin you know moral of
the story just keep dancing like celina
[Music]
and it seems like all that self-love is
paying off i'm constantly somebody that
likes to grow and feel like all right
what could i be better at what could i
do better at work
where could my confidence be stronger
you're probably wondering when season
two of only murders in the building is
going to hit the airway i was wondering
that too i forgot
season two of her hit show only murders
in the building hits hulu on june 28th
seems safe to say selena had the best
time working with her co-stars steve
martin and martin short i could barely
keep a straight face just hanging out
with them it was so wonderful and i
learned so much being around them
they're legends in their own right but
they've you know they're good people
humble funny kind and professional and
it was just the best
and thanks to tick-tock we seemingly
have a glimpse of cell on the set of the
upcoming season four of selina and chef
sometimes i read a text and think what a
[ __ ] psycho
and then i hit send so here's to selena
whether she's laughing at herself last
time i was single i was 24 and the
dating pool was everyone or bringing
that grade a confidence
she's forever our star
[Music]
you